This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Humans have been living in cities for a really long time. But like a lot of things about the past, getting around cities used to be just needlessly difficult because we didn't have reliable maps or street signs or even addresses. And address is something we all take for granted today. But in ancient Rome, if you wanted to go to a friend's house, you had to use all kinds
这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。人类在城市里生活了很长时间。但就像过去的很多事情一样，在城市里四处走动过去简直是不必要地困难，因为我们没有可靠的地图、路标甚至门牌号。门牌号是我们今天视为理所当然的事情。但在古罗马，如果你想去朋友家，你必须使用各种
of context clues. Like yet to remember that the house was two blocks away from a big column. But if you reach the horse tables, you'd go too far. And you had to rely on non-visual cues, like smells and noises. Well, you had all sorts of noise and street hawkers, and you had different smells. You had the smell of a meat market. Yes, sometimes you had to use meat smells
上下文线索。比如你得记住房子距离一根大柱子有两个街区。但如果你到了马厩，你就走过头了。你不得不依赖非视觉线索，比如气味和声音。嗯，你有各种各样的噪音和街头小贩，还有不同的气味。你有肉市的气味。是的，有时你不得不利用肉类的气味
to figure out where you were going. Maybe one of the ways you navigate, you navigate much more by your senses. You can actually use what you're seeing and what you're smelling, and what you're hearing as a ways of navigating around the city. This is Deirdre Mask. I'm the author of the address book, What Street Addresses Reveal about Identity, Race,
来弄清楚你要去哪里。也许你导航的方式之一，是通过你的感官进行更多导航。你实际上可以把你看到的、闻到的以及听到的作为在城市中导航的方式。这是戴尔德丽·马斯。我是《地址簿：街道地址如何揭示身份、种族、
Wealth, and Power. Deirdre's book looks at how the world has changed since street addresses became popular during the Enlightenment. So today, we're going to take a tour through some of the many ways street addresses shaped our lives, including how we fight disease. 54 Fritz Street, London, England, the Office of Dr. John Snow. So street addresses come up in the 1700s and they made all sorts of new things possible. And one of the first things they revolutionized was our approach to public health.
财富与权力》一书的作者。戴尔德丽的书探讨了自启蒙运动期间街道地址普及以来，世界是如何发生变化的。所以今天，我们将游览街道地址塑造我们生活的诸多方式之一，包括我们如何抗击疾病。英国伦敦弗里茨街54号，约翰·斯诺医生的办公室。因此，街道地址出现在18世纪，它们使各种新事物成为可能。它们彻底改变的第一件事就是我们对公共卫生的方法。
So can you tell me how addresses related to the cholera epidemic in London? A doctor called John Snow. This is in the Victorian London. He was actually a very prestigious doctor, but he lived actually right next to a slum. And when a case of cholera broke out in London, he was able to track the cholera in the slum. Now at the time, there was no germ theory of disease, but he had this idea that it was spreading through water, and he was basically able to get desertific hits, get people's addresses, do some shoe leather work himself, and trace where everybody was, and then they clumping around this pump. John Snow took off the handle,
那么你能告诉我地址与伦敦霍乱疫情有什么关系吗？一位名叫约翰·斯诺的医生。这是维多利亚时代的伦敦。他实际上是一位非常著名的医生，但他实际上就住在贫民窟旁边。当伦敦爆发霍乱病例时，他能够追踪贫民窟里的霍乱。当时，还没有疾病的细菌理论，但他有这样一个观点，即霍乱是通过水传播的，他基本上能够获得死亡证明，获取人们的地址，自己做一些实地调查工作，追踪每个人的位置，然后他们聚集在这个水泵周围。约翰·斯诺拔掉了手柄，
or not John Snow himself, the government took off the handle or not Jon Snow himself. The government took off the handle of the pump. The cholera epidemic goes away. He was able to use these location and disease to find the source of the cholera. But speaking of modern epidemiologists, I learned that actually what Jon Snow did in two days in Victorian London is actually impossible and huge swaths of the world today. Yeah, you mentioned the book that countries without good address systems have a much harder time fighting disease.
或者说不是约翰·斯诺本人，政府拔掉了水泵的手柄，或者说不是约翰·斯诺本人。政府拔掉了水泵的手柄。霍乱疫情消失了。他能够利用这些位置和疾病来寻找霍乱的源头。但说到现代流行病学家，我了解到，实际上约翰·斯诺在维多利亚时代的伦敦用两天时间所做的事情，在当今世界的很大一部分地区实际上是不可能的。是的，你提到了书中提到，没有良好地址系统的国家在抗击疾病时要困难得多。
And you bring up Haiti as an example. Tell me what happened there. You know, there was a terrible earthquake as we all know in Haiti in 2010, which was followed by a vicious case of cholera that spread throughout the country. And when I spoke to logisticians at doctors without borders who were coordinating the response to the epidemic, basically, they weren't able to track down their patients in the
你以海地为例。告诉我那里发生了什么。你知道，如我们所知，2010年海地发生了一场可怕的地震，随后是一场猛烈的霍乱疫情，蔓延至全国。当我与无国界医生组织中协调应对疫情的后勤人员交谈时，基本上，他们无法追踪他们的患者，
same way that John Snow could track down the patients in this London slum, which severely hittered their ability to stop the spread of the disease. So it's a complicated story, but basically, if you don't have a way of finally tracking where people are, you don't have a way of finally tracking where people are, you don't have a way of finally tracking where disease is. Adresses have a lot of positive effects like tracing disease and they make it possible for the government to provide services and things like that. But they also give the state a lot of power and that power can be abused. So could you talk about the tyranny of addresses, so to speak? Yes, in the book I talked about the example of Austria
就像约翰·斯诺可以追踪伦敦这个贫民窟的患者一样，这严重阻碍了他们阻止疾病传播的能力。所以这是一个复杂的故事，但基本上，如果你没有一种精确追踪人们所在位置的方法，你也就没有一种精确追踪疾病所在位置的方法。地址有很多积极的影响，比如追踪疾病，它们使政府能够提供服务等等。但它们也赋予了国家很大的权力，而这种权力可能会被滥用。那么，你能谈谈所谓的地址暴政吗？是的，在书中我谈到了奥地利
during the Habsburg Empire, during the reign of Maria Teresa, who had an issue, a problem, which is that she was fighting all these wars and she needed good strong men to fight in the wars, but she was having trouble finding them. So she ended up sending out the military to number the houses in her kingdom and while doing so taking a kind of census. And people did not like these house numbers. And it makes a lot of sense when you think about it, especially if you've never had a number before, because numbering is, as there's a scholar named Anton Tantner, who's written about this extensively, it's dehumanizing. You know, nobody likes to think of themselves as a number.
在哈布斯堡王朝时期、玛丽亚·特蕾西亚统治时期的例子，她有一个问题，那就是她在打所有的这些战争，她需要优秀强壮的男人去打仗，但她在寻找他们时遇到了麻烦。所以她最终派遣军队去给她王国里的房子编号，并在这样做的同时进行某种人口普查。人们非常不喜欢这些门牌号。当你仔细想想时，这是很有道理的，特别是如果你以前从来没有过门牌号的话，因为编号正如一位名叫安东·坦特纳的学者所广泛写到的那样，它是非人化的。你知道，没有人愿意把自己当作一个数字。
But also, it has this function of, if you were able to live your life in relative privacy, and then suddenly you're revealed to the state by a number painted on your wall, there is something deeply upsetting in this. So, this was a good thing in a sense to get numbered because often this assured in positive changes, like, you know, taxes and and getting around and people love the post But there are downsides this as well because now the state can can find you it can imprison you They are all sorts of negative aspects to being found as anyone who's ever received junk mail or solicitations can know it a milder form The story of what happened in Austrian also across Europe as house numbers came up is a story Basically of the conflicting views we have about the state being able to find us and identify us.
但同时，它也有这样的功能：如果你原本能够过着相对隐秘的生活，然后突然间墙上画的一个数字把你暴露给了国家，这其中有着深深的令人不安之处。所以，从某种意义上说，被编号是一件好事，因为这通常会带来积极的变化，比如，税收、出行，人们喜欢邮政。但这也有不利的一面，因为现在国家可以找到你，可以监禁你。正如任何收到过垃圾邮件或推销信的人所知，被找到有着各种各样的负面影响——这是一种温和的形式。奥地利发生的事情以及整个欧洲随着门牌号的出现而发生的事情的故事，基本上是我们对国家能够找到我们并识别我们的相互矛盾的观点的一个故事。
I'd never really considered this inside of addresses until a little while ago, actually, at a friend of mine who was a journalist and long time in Cambodia, the government was trying to impose addresses in parts of Cambodia who, you know, within living memory had genocide and a purge of people. And the citizenry there was like that. Like I don't want the government to have any knowledge of where I am. And I kind of blew my mind because I thought of addresses. I mean, I really didn't think of them at all. I thought of them as neutral things.
直到不久前，我才真正考虑过地址的这一面。实际上，我有一个朋友是记者，长期在柬埔寨工作，政府试图在柬埔寨的部分地区强制推行地址，而在这些地区，在有生之年经历过种族灭绝和大清洗。那里的公民就觉得。就像我不希望政府知道我在哪里一样。这让我大开眼界，因为我以前看待地址——我是说，我根本没怎么想过它们。我以为它们是中立的东西。
Did you notice in your research that, depending on how benevolently you viewed the government and viewed type of control, how people took to the concept of addresses versus people who didn't have that experience? It sounds very familiar to me. And so the way I got started on this whole project, the first thing I wrote about was about West Virginia, about a very rural county in West Virginia called McDowell County, which at the time had no street addresses. The state embarked on a huge project to give them street addresses. And so I went and I interviewed lots and lots of people.
你在研究中是否注意到，根据你对政府的开明程度以及对这种控制的看法，人们对地址概念的接受程度与没有这种经历的人有何不同？这听我听起来非常熟悉。我开始整个项目的过程是这样的，我写的第一件事是关于西弗吉尼亚州的，关于西弗吉尼亚州一个非常偏远的县，叫做麦克道尔县，当时那里没有街道地址。州政府着手开展了一个巨大的项目，给他们提供街道地址。所以我去了，采访了许许多多的人。
And in some ways, it was sort of like a quirky story because people would fight over naming their street Crunchy Grenola Road. There was a street, one official told me, a certain kind of older lady lived on that was called Cougar Lane. It was just, first it was quite quirky. But then you started hearing stories about people who really didn't want addresses. And you talk to the addressing coordinators, and they actually found their work really difficult.
在某些方面，这有点像一个古怪的故事，因为人们会为给他们的街道命名为“脆香格兰诺拉麦片路”而争吵。一位官员告诉我，有一条街，住着一位某种类型的老年妇女，叫做“美洲狮巷”。这只是，首先它相当古怪。但随后你开始听到一些关于人们真的不想要地址的故事。你和地址协调员交谈，他们实际上发现他们的工作非常困难。
And there were reports of people coming out and meeting addresses with machetes in their back pockets. People often say, oh, those are just, you know, they would see them as being ignorant or backwards or, you know, but you know what, the more I read about addresses, the more I realized that they knew a lot of other people didn't knew that these addresses weren't just designed as they were being pitched to provide emergency services, even though that's extremely important. I'm not denying that that's not an excellent reason to give addresses, but they knew there were other benefits to the government of being able to finally track citizens. This was seen as a violent act, actually exposing them to the eye of the state. I guess a lot of it comes down to how much you trust your government as well.
有报道称，有人出来，后兜里揣着大砍刀来面对地址分配人员。人们经常说，哦，那些人只是，你知道，他们会认为这些人是无知的或落后的，或者，你知道，但你知道吗，我读到的关于地址的越多，我就越意识到他们知道许多其他人不知道的事情，这些地址不仅仅是为了向他们推销的那样提供紧急服务而设计的，尽管这极其重要。我不否认这不是提供地址的一个极好的理由，但他们知道政府能够精确追踪公民还有其他好处。这实际上被视为一种暴力的行为，将他们暴露在国家的目光之下。我想这很大程度上也取决于你对政府的信任程度。
Obviously, in the example you gave, if you're dissident or you're someone who the government is not going to like, for whatever reason, you're probably not going to like addresses either. Today, it's believed that over a billion people in the world do not have an address. That includes people without a home and residents of small towns and encampments. And not having an address creates a lot of problems. No fixed address. No fixed address. So you make a case that having an address is actually an equity issue.
显然，在你给出的例子中，如果你是个异见人士，或者出于某种原因，你是政府不喜欢的人，你可能也不会喜欢地址。今天，人们认为世界上有超过十亿人没有地址。这包括无家可归者以及小镇和露营地的居民。没有地址会产生很多问题。没有固定地址。没有固定地址。所以你提出这样一个观点，即拥有地址实际上是一个公平问题。
Not about just having a home, but like having an address. So what does an address give you access to? Well, this really comes up when I was researching homelessness because then you're in my head. I was like, who are the people who don't have addresses? And obviously it's people without homes. And one thing I found from talking to experts on homelessness,
不仅仅是拥有一个家的问题，而是像拥有一个地址的问题。那么，一个地址能为你提供什么权限呢？嗯，当我研究无家可归问题时，这个问题真的浮现了，因为那时候你在我脑海里。我在想，那些没有地址的人都是谁呢？显然是无家可归的人。我从与无家可归问题专家的交谈中发现的一件事，
but also activists, was that when people are asked, when people without homes are asked, what do you need? Well, by definition, they need a home. But what a lot of them said was they needed an address. And so there were stories, you know, of people saying that basically what they needed was a way of pretending that they weren't homeless. When you apply for jobs, it lists address.
还有活动人士，当人们被问及、当无家可归的人被问及，你们需要什么？嗯，根据定义，他们需要一个家。但他们中的许多人说的是，他们需要一个地址。所以有一些故事，你知道，人们说基本上他们需要的是一种假装自己不是无家可归者的方法。当你申请工作时，上面会列出地址。
Even though there's no way you're going to get mail to this address or employers going to show up at your door, but they said they needed an address even if they were just called. Yeah. When you're homeless, it's hard enough to get a job, but you can't even apply for a job in many cases. When they have these mandatory address lines on an application form. The World Bank has seen addresses as one of the cheapest ways of lifting people out of poverty because if you give people addresses, they have a way of pretending that they
尽管你根本不可能把信件寄到这个地址，雇主也不会出现在你的门前，但他们说他们需要一个地址，哪怕他们只是租来的。是的。当你无家可归时，找工作已经够难了，但在很多情况下，你甚至无法申请工作。当他们在申请表格上有这些强制性的地址栏时。世界银行将地址视为将人们摆脱贫困的最便宜的方法之一，因为如果你给人们地址，他们就有一种假装自己
aren't homeless in a way of accessing all kinds of services. So to go back to your question, there's all sorts of things you can't do. You'll struggle to get a bank account, you'll struggle to vote, you know, where I live in England, and there's a national health service. Almost all communication is done through letters. And when I was researching this, I was calling up GP practices to find out how you register while being homeless. And even though I am a person with a home, I found it incredibly difficult to get out
不是无家可归者的方法，也是一种获得各种服务的方法。所以回到你的问题，有各种各样你做不到的事情。你很难拥有一个银行账户，你很难投票，你知道，在我居住的英国，有一个国民保健制度。几乎所有的沟通都是通过信件完成的。当我在研究这个时，我打电话给全科医生诊所，想了解如何在无家可归的情况下进行登记。尽管我是一个有家的人，但我发现要弄清楚这一点
to even pretend for my, you know, investigating into homelessness, but on that incredibly difficult. Is there a way to level the playing field for people without addresses? Yeah, so one of the proposals that's been made is something called BAM the address, which has been modeled on this BAM the box movement in the US, and by the box it means not allowing employers to ask about your criminal history, basically stopping people from discriminating at first glance against someone. And there's something similar about BAM the address. There's no reason that employers need your address,
甚至为了我（你知道的）对无家可归者的调查假装一下，都极其困难。有没有什么方法可以为没有地址的人创造一个公平的竞争环境呢？是的，所以有人提出的一项提议叫做“禁止地址栏”（Ban the Address），它是以美国“禁止犯罪记录栏”（Ban the Box）运动为蓝本的，“禁止犯罪记录栏”是指不允许雇主询问你的犯罪历史，基本上是阻止人们在第一眼就歧视某人。关于“禁止地址栏”也有类似的情况。雇主没有理由需要你的地址，
at least at those early stages of interview process. There's also a very clever way that's become come up with in England by a man named Chris Hildry, where he's basically teaming up with royal mail to use the addresses of empty homes so that if you could just be assigned the address of an empty home, and you could use this and the mail does not go to the house, you know, even if the home gets moved into it doesn't matter.
至少在面试过程的早期阶段是这样。英国有一个名叫克里斯·希尔德里（Chris Hildry）的人想出了一个非常巧妙的方法，他基本上与英国皇家邮政合作，利用空置房屋的地址，这样如果你能被分配到一个空置房屋的地址，你就可以使用它，而且邮件不会寄到那个房子，你知道，即使有人搬进了那个房子也没关系。
It's the same way as if you move your mail gets forwarded for months and the people currently living there will have no idea this is happening. And so people can get the letters that they need, but they can also use it as a shield showing to people that they have an address which sometimes becomes a proxy for, you know, a productive member of society. A street address can indicate that someone's been fortunate in life. Many streets like Park Avenue in New York have become associated with luxury and prestige.
这就像如果你搬家了，你的邮件会被转发几个月，而目前住在那里的人根本不知道发生了什么。因此，人们可以收到他们需要的信件，但他们也可以将其用作一面盾牌，向人们展示他们有一个地址，有时这会成为社会高产成员的代名词。街道地址可以表明某人在生活中很幸运。许多街道，如纽约的公园大道，已成为奢华和声望的代名词。
While others have developed preputations as bad neighborhoods, reputations that are sometimes totally unfair. has bad neighborhoods, reputations that are sometimes totally unfair. One Martin Luther King Jr. Boulevard, Atlanta, Georgia. There are hundreds of Martin Luther King streets in America. They're often in neighborhoods that are less well off. Why is that? What is the cycle that has created the idea
而其他街道则形成了糟糕街区的名声，这些名声有时完全是不公平的。成为糟糕街区的名声，这些名声有时完全是不公平的。乔治亚州亚特兰大马丁·路德·金大道。美国有数百条以马丁·路德·金命名的街道。它们通常位于不太富裕的街区。这是为什么呢？是什么循环创造了这个想法
and the stigma of Martin Luther King? I think the estimate now is 900 streets named after Martin Luther King Jr. in America today. And they're often interestingly enough in the American South right next to the names of Confederate generals. And commemorating a street after Martin Luther King, who was obviously the most prominent icon of the Civil Rights Movement,
以及对马丁·路德·金的污名化？我想现在的估计是，今天美国有900条以马丁·路德·金的名字命名的街道。有趣的是，它们通常位于美国南方，紧挨着南方邦联将军的名字。为了纪念马丁·路德·金，他显然是民权运动中最杰出的偶像，
largely he was black communities that named streets after Martin Luther King as a way of commemorating him. Sometimes they were put in neighborhoods to inspire the residents, I put inspiring quotes, but in some of these situations these were neighborhoods that didn't work particularly nice to put a point on it because of the forces of racism and poverty. And this meant that the name for some people was entrenched with this idea of poverty and crime. And it's why Chris Rock, you know, in his stand-up had a routine in which I'm paraphrasing, but, you know, if you find yourself on Martin Luther King, Junior Street Run. It ain't the safest place to fit. You can't call nobody, tell them you lost on MLK. I'm lost, I'm on Martin Luther King Run!
很大程度上是黑人社区以马丁·路德·金的名字命名街道，以此来纪念他。有时它们被安置在街区里以激励居民，我放了一些鼓舞人心的名言，但在某些情况下，由于种族主义和贫困的力量，这些街区并不是特别好。这意味着对某些人来说，这个名字根深蒂固地与贫困和犯罪联系在一起。这就是为什么克里斯·洛克（Chris Rock），你知道，在他的单口喜剧中有一个桥段，我在意译，但是，你知道，如果你发现自己在马丁·路德·金初级大街上，快跑。这不是一个最安全的地方。你不能打电话给任何人，告诉他们在MLK迷路了。我迷路了，我在马丁·路德·金街！
Run! Run! Run! The video's there! Everybody laughed at me, you know, I'm black myself, I laughed as well. But you know, in a lot of ways, it's not funny at all. And sometimes you can track MLK streets and find out about Black America.
快跑！快跑！快跑！视频在那儿！每个人都嘲笑我，你知道，我自己也是黑人，我也笑了。但你知道，在很多方面，这根本不好笑。有时你可以追踪MLK街并了解黑人美国。
But also, you can find about the perception of Black America as well. Because one thing I found in my research was that there are researchers, for example, who have found that if you compare the economic fortunes of streets, same after Martin Luther King, with streets, same after JFK, or even with just main streets, MLK streets aren't that much economically worse off.
但同时，你也可以了解对黑人美国的看法。因为我在研究中发现的一件事是，例如，有些研究人员发现，如果你把以马丁·路德·金命名的街道的经济命运与以肯尼迪命名的街道，甚至与普通的主街进行比较，MLK街道的经济状况并没有那么糟糕。
You know, they're different. They have more churches, for example, or they have more, you know, more schools, because these are white collar jobs that were open to black people. But they weren't any worse. And one of the conclusions that I come to when I write about this is that, you know, yes, a lot of these streets have suffered, but also perhaps we think of MLK's junior streets as dangerous streets because they're black streets
你知道，它们是不同的。例如，它们有更多的教堂，或者它们有更多的学校，因为这些是对黑人开放的白领工作。但它们并不更糟。当我写到这一点时，我得出的结论之一是，你知道，是的，许多这些街道都遭受了苦难，但也许我们也认为MLK初级大街是危险的街道，因为它们是黑人街道，
and we're always gonna associate black streets with being dangerous and poor and neglected. And thinking about that is another way of thinking about race in America today. Today, more and more streets around the world are named after famous people from history, and this is why street names have become a proxy for so many arguments about who we are and what we stand for. The British Embassy at Ferd book was about the Bobby Sand Street
而且我们总是把黑人街道与危险、贫穷和被忽视联系在一起。思考这一点是思考当今美国种族问题的另一种方式。今天，世界上越来越多的街道以历史上的名人命名，这就是为什么街名已经成为关于我们是谁以及我们代表什么的大量争论的代名词。费尔德书中的英国大使馆是关于
in Tehran. There's this incredible tense history between the UK and Iran, and making a Bobby Sand Street makes it, it seems like a real provocation. How did it end up that there was a Bobby Sand Street in Tehran? Yeah, it's interesting. There is a Bobby Sand Street in Tehran, which is right by the British Embassy. And for anybody who doesn't know,
德黑兰的鲍比·桑兹街（Bobby Sands Street）。英国和伊朗之间有着这种令人难以置信的紧张历史，设立一条鲍比·桑兹街似乎是一个真正的挑衅。德黑兰怎么会有一条鲍比·桑兹街呢？是的，这很有趣。德黑兰有一条鲍比·桑兹街，就在英国大使馆旁边。对于任何不知道的人来说，
Bobby Sand's was a hunger striker in Northern Ireland, a member of the Irish Republican Army. And so it was an unusual name to have in Tehran, especially by the British Embassy, because the British really were Bobby Sands's enemies. Yeah, I'd heard the story about these teenage boys who had changed it, so I tracked one of them down. Who told me this amazing story that,
鲍比·桑兹是北爱尔兰的一名绝食抗议者，也是爱尔兰共和军的成员。所以在德黑兰有一个这样的名字很不寻常，特别是挨着英国大使馆，因为英国人真的是鲍比·桑兹的敌人。是的，我听说过关于这些十几岁的男孩改变了它的故事，所以我找到了其中一个人。他告诉我这个神奇的故事，
after the revolution, there were a lot of young people who were very politically involved, including himself. We'd gotten involved in politics at a very young age, and they're very wealthy residents of Tehran, so they're in quite a fancy neighborhood near the British Embassy, and they had this idea they were gonna change the names. Sounds to me a bit like, you know, stranger things.
革命后，有很多年轻人非常积极地参与政治，包括他自己。我们在很小的时候就参与了政治，他们是德黑兰非常富有的人，所以他们在英国大使馆附近一个相当高档的街区，他们有一个想法，他们要改名。在我听来有点像，你知道，《怪奇物语》。
They're all on their bikes going to the hardware store and they buy this glue that they have to powder and mix water and then they're basically able to mimic signs and they change the sands to read Bobby Sandstree, and this would have been shortly after Bobby Sandstide, after his hunger strike. The city later ratified it and there's Bobby Sandstree, and weirdly enough for a hunger strike or there's a Bobby Sand's burger bar.
他们都骑着自行车去五金店，买这种他们必须弄成粉末并加水混合的胶水，然后他们基本上能够模仿标志，他们把桑兹改成了“鲍比·桑兹街”（Bobby Sands Street），这应该是在鲍比·桑兹死后不久，在他绝食抗议之后。该市后来批准了它，于是就有了鲍比·桑兹街，奇怪的是，对于一个绝食抗议者来说，那里有一个鲍比·桑兹汉堡店。
Oh my god. Also in Tehran. And the reason I found this fascinating was that it's just a light on commemoration. Why does this matter? And in fact, we know it does matter because the British Embassy actually ended up opening up a new entrance so that they didn't have to be on Bobby Sandstreet, which I believe used to be Winston Churchill Street, you know, so they could have a new address because obviously they cared.
哦天哪。也在德黑兰。我发现这很吸引人的原因是，它只是阐明了纪念活动。为什么这很重要？事实上，我们知道这确实很重要，因为英国大使馆实际上最终开辟了一个新入口，这样他们就不必在鲍比·桑兹街上了，我相信这条街以前叫温斯顿·丘吉尔街，你知道，这样他们就可以有一个新地址，因为显然他们在乎。
And so it opens this window of what commemoration means and why we care so much really. Yeah, they were angry at the British Empire and they knew that Bobby Sand's would be a finger in their eye, basically, you know, just like it just could poke them. Yeah, so there's Bobby S. H. to Toronto, but there's Bobby Sand Street all over the world, you know, just like it just would poke them. Yeah, so there's Bobby S. Taron, but there's Bobby Sandstreet all over the world, you know, I think I kind of five in France, for example. But the interesting thing I found was that there aren't any actually in Ireland, so this is actually sort of a fascinating idea that you have this fighter who, for a lot of people depending on your belief system, would have been a martyr and a great man. And yet you have all these names and bathroom elsewhere.
所以它打开了一扇窗户，让我们了解纪念意味着什么，以及为什么我们如此真正在乎。是的，他们对大英帝国感到愤怒，他们知道鲍比·桑兹基本上会成为戳在他们眼里的手指，你知道，就像惹恼他们一样。是的，德黑兰有鲍比·S·H，但世界各地都有鲍比·桑兹街，你知道，就像惹恼他们一样。是的，德黑兰有鲍比·S·T，但世界各地都有鲍比·桑兹街，你知道，我想法国大概有五条吧。但我发现有趣的是，爱尔兰实际上没有任何一条，所以这实际上是一个迷人的想法，你有这样一位战士，对许多人来说，根据你的信仰系统，他会是一个烈士和一个伟人。然而你在其他地方有所有这些名字和浴室。
But you don't have any in Ireland. And basically the explanation I came to is that Ireland doesn't have any consensus on Bobby Sands. Up close, his legacy is a lot more complicated than it was for those teenage boys in Iran. This whole idea of commemorating is really trying to figure out what we're about. And what Ireland has said by not giving a Bob Sands
但在爱尔兰却没有。我得出的基本解释是，爱尔兰对鲍比·桑兹没有任何共识。近距离来看，他的遗产比伊朗那些十几岁的男孩所经历的要复杂得多。这种纪念的整个想法实际上是试图弄清楚我们是什么。爱尔兰通过没有给予鲍比·桑兹
street is that at this point, at least that's out what we're about, and what Ireland has said by not giving a Bob-San street is that at this point, at least that's not what they're about. You know, Bobby Sands is Ireland, is not today's Ireland, and that's really for me why there is no street name after Bobby Sands in Ireland, or North or South. 2-2-1-1 Freedom Street, Hollywood, Florida. So right now, there are lots of arguments about street names, especially in the US where they're named after Confederate generals and historical figures like Christopher Columbus.
一条街道，在这一点上表明，至少这不是我们的全部，爱尔兰通过没有给予鲍比·桑兹一条街道表明，至少在这一点上，这不是他们的全部。你知道，鲍比·桑兹是爱尔兰，但不是今天的爱尔兰，对我来说，这就是为什么爱尔兰（无论南北）没有以鲍比·桑兹命名的街道的原因。佛罗里达州好莱坞自由街2211号。所以现在，关于街名有很多争论，特别是在美国，它们以南方邦联将军和克里斯托弗·哥伦布等历史人物命名。
And you spent months covering street names in Hollywood, Florida in particular. So what was happening in Hollywood, Florida when you were there? Yeah, well in Hollywood, Florida, there were parts of the city that were historically black. Part of the city called Liberia had three street names that were named after Confederate generals. And the worst of them of all in the eyes of campaigners was Nathan Bedford Forest Street. People knew who Nathan Bedford Forest was.
你花了几个月的时间报道佛罗里达州好莱坞的街名，特别是。那么当你在那里时，佛罗里达州好莱坞发生了什么？是的，嗯，在佛罗里达州的好莱坞，有些城区历史上是黑人区。城市中一个叫利比里亚（Liberia）的部分有三条街名是以南方邦联将军命名的。在活动人士眼中，其中最糟糕的是内森·贝德福德·福斯特街（Nathan Bedford Forest Street）。人们知道内森·贝德福德·福斯特是谁。
He was not only, he was, you know, a major figure in the Confederate war, but he was also seen as one of the founders of the Ku Klux Klan. And so you have these street names, not only in this part of Hollywood, Florida, that was really intended for black people, when black people weren't allowed to live
他不仅是南方邦联战争中的一个重要人物，而且他也被视为三K党的创始人之一。所以你有这些街名，不仅在这个佛罗里达州好莱坞的那个真正为黑人指定的地区，当时黑人不被允许居住
in integrated areas. And so there was an activist, a man who actually just recently passed away, I'm sad to say, in Benjamin, Israel, is a really interesting man, who's from New York, he's African-American, but also orthodox Jewish. And he basically just for months, just appeared at every city council meeting. And I watched many of these things, you know, where he would be talking about these street
在一体化地区。所以有一个活动家，一个我悲伤地说最近刚刚去世的人，本杰明·以色列（Benjamin Israel），一个非常有趣的人，他来自纽约，他是非裔美国人，但也是正统犹太人。他基本上只是连续几个月出现在每一次市议会会议上。我观看了许多这样的会议，你知道，他在那里谈论这些街
names while everybody else was talking about Airbnb regulations. And finally, it really started to click. And eventually, they did overturn them. And it really, in a lot of ways, exposed a lot of racism, but also a lot of other feelings about street names in the battle. And for me, one of the most interesting thing was, you know, I'm African-American. I did, yeah, in the book in general, I tried to stay fairly neutral about these things, but I'm not really neutral in this. I thought the street names would change. But it was interesting hearing the other side, and I listened to
名，而其他所有人都在谈论Airbnb的规定。最后，它真的开始引起反响了。最终，他们确实推翻了这些街名。在很多方面，它确实暴露了许多种族主义，但也暴露了人们对战斗中街名的许多其他感受。对我来说，最有趣的事情之一是，你知道，我是非裔美国人。我确实，是的，在书中总的来说，我试图对这些事情保持相当中立，但在这件事上我并不是真正中立的。我以为街名会改变。但听到另一面很有趣，我听了
it, you know, many speeches about this, that there were people who would say things like, I live on Lee Street, named after Robert E. Lee, and I don't care anything about Robert E. Lee, but you know, I met my husband on Lee Street, my babies were born on Lee Street, I wanted to be Lee Street, and my head, I connected to that, which makes a lot of sense, because in our brain, we do tend to connect place and memory. So it makes sense to me. I'm not actually promoting Lee, I just like the name Lee. And I think that now the conversation has changed. And it's like, we can't just rest on this nostalgia argument. Even if you say, you're not actually racist.
关于这方面的许多演讲，你知道，有些人会说这样的话：我住在李街（Lee Street），以罗伯特·E·李（Robert E. Lee）命名，我不在乎罗伯特·E·李是谁，但你知道，我在李街遇到了我的丈夫，我的孩子在李街出生，我希望它是李街，在我的脑海里，我与那个地方建立了联系，这很有意义，因为在我们的脑海里，我们确实倾向于将地点和记忆联系起来。所以这对我来说很有意义。我其实并不是在宣传李，我只是喜欢李这个名字。我认为现在的对话已经改变了。就像，我们不能只停留在这种怀旧的论点上。即使你说，你实际上并不种族主义。
And I actually believe this, I don't actually think this, you know, for a lot of the people, this was a show of racism. But it's this idea now that I think people are having this thing, well, we just have to change them. You know, you have to take action to change them, which I think was often missing. But in Hollywood, Florida, they did change the street names. Yeah. And so what did you think of the solution of Hollywood, Florida?
我其实也相信这一点，我其实不认为，你知道，对很多人来说，这是种族主义的表现。但现在的这个想法是，我认为人们有这样一种看法，嗯，我们必须改变它们。你知道，你必须采取行动去改变它们，我认为这通常是缺失的。但在佛罗里达州的好莱坞，他们确实改了街名。是的。那么你对佛罗里达州好莱坞的解决方案有什么看法？
They didn't replace, like, Robert Lee Street with, like, so rights icons. They replaced him with, like, freedom street and hope street. So what do you think of that outcome? This became a debate as well over the course of the talk, because people wanted to name it after an activist, for example, who helped integrate beaches in Florida and they're like, there was even a suggestion at some point by one council member to just number the streets,
他们没有用民权偶像取代罗伯特·李街。他们用自由街和希望街取代了它。那么你对这个结果怎么看？在讨论的过程中，这也成为了一场辩论，因为人们希望以一位活动家的名字来命名，例如，他帮助实现了佛罗里达州海滩的种族融合，甚至有一位议员在某个时候建议只给街道编上号，
it's obviously an American solution. And then nobody wanted that either. And then I would think about it as like, well, why is that, I mean, just thinking about it from an objective standpoint, why is that such a bad solution to number of streets? And the reason is that street names have become like monuments away where we preserve our memories.
这显然是一个美式解决方案。然后也没有人想要这个。然后我会思考这个问题，我的意思是，从客观的角度来看，为什么把街道编号是一个这么糟糕的解决方案？原因在于街道街名已经变成了纪念碑，一种我们保存记忆的方式。
And there have been a lot of historians, Pierre Nora, comes to mind. We talk about history moving incredibly quickly. This idea of the acceleration of history that things just changed so fast that we really have to start salting away and packing away our memories into things so that we don't forget when things start to change again. And I think that's why
有很多历史学家，皮埃尔·诺拉（Pierre Nora）浮现在脑海中。我们谈到历史移动得不可思议地快。历史加速的概念，即事情变化得如此之快，以至于我们真的必须开始将我们的记忆腌制并打包进事物中，这样当事情再次开始变化时我们才不会忘记。我想这就是为什么
suggestions like numbering don't fly because it's not just that people don't want Robert E. Lee's name down. They want to make a statement and they want their street names to make a statement. So it's not simply about the taking down, it's the putting up as well. And so hope liberty and freedom ended up being something that united people in some sense. But yes, the bolder move would have been to actually name it after an activist who actually fought against the principles that the Confederate generals were aiming for. Yeah. Anything that's solution is okay, like that compromise of a freedom hope and liberty. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's interesting. I mean, it's not really for me to say whether it's okay or not,
编号这样的建议行不通的原因，因为人们不仅是不希望罗伯特·E·李的名字留下来。他们想发表一个声明，他们希望他们的街名发表一个声明。所以这不仅仅是关于拆除，也是关于竖立。因此，“希望”、“自由”和“独立”最终在某种程度上成为了团结人们的东西。但是，是的，更大胆的举动实际上是以一位真正反对南方邦联将军目标的原则的活动家的名字来命名它。是的。任何解决方案都可以，比如自由、希望和独立的妥协。我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，这很有趣。我的意思是，这真的不由我来评判它是否可以，
but at the same time, I mean, people often decry these arguments are terrible. I mean, I like these arguments. I mean, as I say in the book, you know, arguments divide communities, but they make communities as well. You know, if we didn't have these arguments, they simply numbered if they simply changed it. I think actually there's a lot to be gained from people talking and listening. Even now, I know people don't often listen, but there's engagement there.
但与此同时，我的意思是，人们经常谴责这些争论是可怕的。我的意思是，我喜欢这些争论。我的意思是，正如我在书中说的，你知道，争论分裂了社区，但也构建了社区。你知道，如果我们没有这些争论，如果他们只是编号，如果他们只是改变了它。我认为人们交谈和倾听实际上有很多好处。即使现在，我知道人们往往不经常倾听，但那里有互动。
There's an exposure there. We're trying to decide what these things mean for a society. For Hollywood, they decided that hope, liberty, and freedom would be great. Obviously, in a lot of ways, I think it would have been even better had they pushed it further from my own personal perspective. I do like that there's this process through street names often that, you know, exposes what people believe and what they believe their community is about. And I think that's valuable.
那里有一种曝光。我们试图决定这些事情对一个社会意味着什么。对于好莱坞来说，他们决定希望、自由和独立会很棒。显然，在许多方面，我认为如果他们把事情推得更远，从我个人的角度来看会更好。我确实喜欢这种通过街名通常发生的过程，你知道，它暴露了人们的信仰以及他们认为他们的社区是关于什么的。我认为这是有价值的。
As more of our life becomes digital, our physical address is becoming obsolete. More with Deer Dramask after this. Soap Heavy Pounds, Oakland, California. We don't really need addresses anymore. You mentioned this, that there are ways to get a driver's license or pay or taxes. You can do a lot of stuff online. Could you imagine a world without addresses in the future? Oh, yeah, I know I absolutely could. I mean, you kind of imagine in some developing countries that they're going to bypass addresses altogether for something more digital. Yeah, and there are lots of companies that are really getting that.
随着我们越来越多的生活变成数字化的，我们的物理地址正在变得过时。接下来的节目将带来更多关于戴尔德丽·马斯的访谈。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市索普重磅磅。我们其实不再需要地址了。你提到了这一点，有办法获得驾照或支付税款。你可以在网上做很多事情。你能想象未来没有地址的世界吗？哦，是的，我知道我绝对可以。我的意思是，你可以想象在一些发展中国家中，他们将完全绕过地址，转而采用更数字化的东西。是的，有很多公司真的在这样做。
Google's gotten them the act. They've got a great sort of digital system. There's this company I described called What Three Words, which is given addresses in just three basically random words that they've mapped the whole world. So I can in some ways imagine it. Could you describe what three words and how it serves as an alternative to physical addresses? Basically this company has divided up the world. I believe it's three meters by three meter squares, but I could be wrong about that, but very small chunks. And they basically given every single one of these squares a three word
谷歌已经参与进来了。他们有一个很棒的数字化系统。有一家我描述过叫做“what3words”的公司，它仅用三个基本上随机的词语就给出了地址，他们绘制了整个世界的地图。所以在某种程度上我可以想象。你能描述一下what3words以及它是如何作为物理地址的替代品的吗？基本上这家公司把世界划分开了。我相信是三米乘三米的方格，但我可能记错了，但非常小的块。他们基本上给每一个这样的方格赋予了一个三个词的
address. It's not a street name like we think of they've given it three words so I clicked on a random spot not too far from where I live that's you know create door statue. You know three entirely random words and point of this is that you can isolate things much much quicker you know just three meters by three meters and also you can find things much, much quicker, you know, just three meters by three meters. And also, you can find things that generally don't have addresses like the middle of a park, you know, if you're on a hike and you want to map out where you took a picture, you can use the Wethree words address. But they've also been used in places that don't have addresses. So
地址。它不是我们想象的那种街名，他们给它三个词，所以我点击了离我住的地方不远的一个随机地点，那是，你知道，创造 门 雕像。你知道三个完全随机的词，这样做的目的是你可以更快地隔离事物，你知道，只有三米乘三米，而且你也可以更快地找到事物，你知道，只需三米乘三米。此外，你可以找到通常没有地址的东西，比如公园的正中央，如果你在远足并且想标出你拍照的地方，你可以使用what3words地址。但它们也被用于没有地址的地方。所以
they've been used, for example, in Mongolia, where there isn't the traditional street addressing system that we're familiar with say in the US. And you can remember it because you can remember three words pretty easily as opposed to like some map coordinates which are very long and abstract stringing numbers. But what is the limitations of something like what three words? Well, I mean, one of the limitations, I think of all of this is that I spoke earlier about how, you know, the state was in control of addresses, but in a lot of ways, we tend to trust states more than we trust companies. I mean, let's see if that's true anymore, but in general, in general, we do this idea. So you have a component of what three words, which I think has come up
它们被用在例如蒙古，那里没有我们所熟悉的传统街道寻址系统，比如在美国。你可以记住它，因为你可以相当容易地记住三个词，而不是像非常长且抽象的数字串那样的地图坐标。但像what3words这样的东西有什么局限性呢？嗯，我的意思是，局限性之一，我认为所有这一切都是，我之前说过，你知道，国家控制着地址，但在很多情况下，我们往往比信任公司更信任国家。我的意思是，让我们看看这是否仍然属实，但总的来说，总的来说，我们有这种想法。所以你有what3words的一个组成部分，我认为它想出了这种聪明的发明，但它们是一家私营公司。这项what3words技术受到专利的约束。使用它，你不能像使用你的地址那样自由地使用它们。这确实意味着你有点受制于一家私营公司来弄清楚你在哪里。不知为何，这让我感到非常不舒服。此外，它夺走了意义。我们讨论了所有这些纪念性街名，以及街名如何具有无论好坏的意义。地址是我们在这个世界上导航的方式，当我们把我们自己与其他人联系起来时。所以许多这些数字地址的一个问题是，你变成了一串数字
with this sort of brilliant invention, but they are a private company. This what three words technology is bound up in patents. Using it, you can't use them as freely as you could use your addresses. It does mean that you're sort of beholden to a private company to find out where you are in a little ways. And that something about that makes me really uncomfortable. Also, it takes away the meaning. We talked all about these commemorative street names and how street names have meaning for better or for worse. Addresses are sort of the way we navigate the world when we connect ourselves to other people. So one problem with a lot of these digital addresses is that you become a string of numbers
或者在what3words的情况下，是一串没有把我们和我们的邻居联系起来，也没有把我们和我们的社区联系起来的词。所以我认为它有很多用途，特别是对于没有传统地址的地方或其他用途，但我仍然希望坚定地坚持我们的传统地址。本周的《99%隐形》由克里斯·巴鲁布（Chris Baroube）制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。
or in what three words case, a string of words that don't connect us to our neighbors or don't connect us to our communities. So I think it has many uses, especially for places that don't have traditional addresses or for these others' uses, but I still would like to hold firm to our traditional addresses. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, music by Sean Riel.
或者以“three words”（三个词）定位为例，一串无法将我们与邻居或社区联系起来的词语。因此，我认为它有许多用途，特别是对于没有传统地址的地方或其他用途，但我仍然希望坚守我们的传统地址。《99% Invisible》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。
Our senior producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Abby Madon, Christopher Johnson, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project in 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the North American continent, but will always be centered. And beautiful. Downtown. Oakland, California. We're a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of
我们的高级制作人是德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、艾比·马顿（Abby Madon）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，制作于无线电街（Radio Row），该街散布在北美大陆各地，但永远以美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为中心。我们是PRX旗下独立集体RadioTopia的创始成员
the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned and operated podcast in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and read it too. We have lots of new merch in a 99PI store, including a Mabyee masks and t-shirts with funiculars on them, plus we have links to purchase the 99% Invisible City. It's the new book, it's out October 6th. It's all at 99PI.org.
这个由最具创新精神的听众支持的、100%由艺术家拥有和运营的播客网络。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解全部内容。你可以在 Twitter 上通过 Roman Mars 或 @99PIorg 找到我，Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。我们的 99PI 商店里有很多新周边，包括 Mabyee 口罩和印有缆车图案T恤，此外我们还有购买《99%隐形城市》（99% Invisible City）新书的链接，该书将于10月6日发售。所有内容都在 99PI.org。
Radio Topea from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radiotopia 出品，来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。